you know when you look at someone so
differently they physically look
different
wow
[Music]
all right guys we're back and you
already know as we do we go straight
into the nitty gritty and the question
of the week was what is a deal breaker
and a friendship oh
also up and down I was expecting yeah
because a lot of the answers
well let me preface it I had faith in
the gang right in the streets in the
squad I was expecting funny funnies like
funny funnies a lot of people are giving
me like relationship stuff but I was
like this is Frank I said friendship
friendship yeah they're going to give
relationships that's all they care about
they have relationship stuff but
I had to weed my way through the
[__] and I found some gems gang all
right cool gems cool cool what we got
making Tick-Tock Dance videos and being
tired
bro
bro okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
matches sense I read that and I thought
to myself imagine
imagine I came to the studio like early
at like 10 o'clock or something just set
up you man then I just flipped that
camera around and I'm just here dancing
doing up all of this stuff and what are
you my walk in one day
Ellis walks in early one day and just
catches you're just there he just
catches me don't I'm like oh and you're
just trash I'm trashing I'm sweating
yeah I'm just livid and I leave and I
walk back out come in at like one thing
just pretend I've never been here deal
breaker for me is actually
um
deal breaker for me in that exact thing
is asking me to do Tick Tock with you oh
facts you could never ask me I'm not
doing Tick Tock I'm not doing be real
I'm not doing none of these things yeah
don't ask me for stuff yeah there's one
there's one I've never I don't care
about Tito Trends there's one MJ Trend
going around at the minute okay
um the um oh what's the
oh you rock oh yeah
I've seen it on the triple but people
are just doing the You Rock My World
yeah yeah just the yeah and he's doing
that yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
shoulder thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've seen it I've seen it
and they're coming with the
I love it well I love it bro yeah
oh
is this hot tea yeah bro yeah I see
everybody doing a treadmill looks it
looks smooth
I want to do it I don't want to
Tick-Tock it but I want to do it bro see
they've still got it see if he's still
oh I love seeing it every time it comes
up that's jokes found out my old mate
referred to me as her gutter friend
because she goes to a posh uni
my gutter friend got her friend she goes
Nottingham Trent my gutter thing oh she
goes my gutting
so big what's that so big oh University
no not University of Birmingham city
that's a God thing that's a guy that's a
guy thing still what's what Lester
what's the last what's not Lester what's
the other one the month that's what I
said yeah yeah dmu yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Tarts in there I remember everyone used
to sell me dmu they said the ratio was
brazy yes it was 70 30. yeah yeah yeah
obviously I didn't even get in but when
I went there yeah anyway yeah yeah
there's jokes
ah lifting up my girl knowing full well
I can't
Ah that's not even a friendship that's
that's a relationship thing yeah yeah
lifted up my gun I went down well I
can't yeah
that's intense man because I hate
knowing that the girl knows you can't
either and she knew that from the jump
as well she knew that from the job I
told you that one time I I fell over
picking up a thing I don't remember who
you have but I genuinely don't remember
listen to me now um
oh God because you know who the thing is
as well she was sturdy okay this is uni
times before like
this is this is this is how I know what
it was but just before we were doing leg
days properly okay this is when we were
doing like just leg press okay leg
pressing a bit of coughs yeah I would
call it a day yeah yeah for a roll
before I before my squad game was Elite
this is probably first or second year of
uni
I was um
sleeping with this girl
you know who it is and um one day I was
in her room she lived in uh what's that
bottle that you lived in Priory
Priory I know who it is no no she didn't
know she didn't live there when you
lived there oh okay yeah yeah she was a
year younger than us okay one day she
was stradded across my lap yeah I was
like yeah yeah yeah yeah enter the bed
yeah stranded across my lap and the
bed's low so you can already see the
thigh angle like um
I'm coming from the pocket yeah yeah I'm
squatting out of pocket yeah yeah ask
the grass already yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah hamstring and car for touching
yeah yeah I'm coming straight out of
pocket yeah and she's a strong yeah
she's like
a good 75 kilos okay 80 kilos okay
sturdy tank okay fam am I talking 10
years ago yeah I was weak yeah in body
of mind I was weak what's your mind
bro body of mine was weak yeah I thought
yeah let me help me hold this
stood up in me because obviously as well
the way it's not parallel yeah so that
gravitation
yanked me forward and how I wasn't doing
deadlifts and Eva so my Erectors they
didn't know what just happened fam we
were lips and lips and lips in picked
her up immediately fell forward off the
bed onto the off the bed and I'm bent
over now and she's like yeah finger lock
in the back of my neck yeah yeah yeah so
I had to shake her off my neck she had
to fall alone because I would have fell
on top of her I couldn't have it so she
she fell back in one reflex shook her
off my neck oh wow smacked ahead on the
floor wow I don't think you've ever told
me this maybe how about I generally
don't remember bro yeah I probably
didn't now that I'm reliving it yeah I
probably didn't I probably came straight
home and shut up
embarrassing bro fair enough
damn embarrassing bro was this like
addressed or discussed or like was it
like a all right bless no I stayed there
for a little while longer but I don't
remember how we got over it I don't
remember how we got over all the noise I
didn't bang it that day oh I know for a
fact okay yeah it was a nightmare say
less I bet you I bet
um what's the deal breaker at a
friendship putting milk in before the
tea bag what exactly bro
so are they doing milk tea bag than
water it must be milk because I know
hang on milk yeah I guess milk tea bag
then you've got the tea milk yeah that
gray milk and then water that's Bonkers
that sounds diluted that's just
backwards bro yeah yeah I'm not doing
that
when they can't behave in public places
Fair do I have a friend like that I
don't I don't think but I can understand
I like one yeah I've seen we've all been
places where we just see other
friendship groups you see that one
person in French just acting crazy bro I
feel like edits must have a friend like
that because white people
they just don't like that they have one
friend who gets drunk and does wild [__]
yeah I'm actually trying to think maybe
some people from college yeah yeah bro
you just can't take out with a group
with the rest of it that was like one of
my boys back in the day he knows how to
act in public but you couldn't take him
out promise he's fighting oh promise you
he's fighting someone oh God it was the
most stressful thing
that's jarring when they don't like
roller coasters yeah yeah I don't know
if is that a deal breaker I want to say
it's a okay that's that's a lot but I
understand how often I understand is
jaram how often are we just don't bring
me that day
if we're doing that for a park I just
want to come yeah but I don't it doesn't
mean we can't be friends
I'll tell you that fair but also yeah
it's a roller coaster man up you know
yeah yeah yeah that time we went last
time we went through popcorn was
hungover yeah yeah
worst day of my life I know you are
you're struggling that I found worse
than my life I was engulfed in the whole
thing yeah you're loving it yeah because
I was ready to chalk up the whole day
we've done everything I thought I'd
given I thought I'd given you enough
yeah do you know what I mean I put I
told you from the jump I'm not on it
yeah I don't want to be here yeah let's
just get through the day
your energy somehow just Rose and Rose
rose through the other day and I I
really really felt like I'd given you
enough
and then you were like stealth let's go
oh yeah
we can joke about it as long as we need
to joke about it but I promise you at
the end we'll get on it when I was on it
I was living bro we're at the front of
the queue yeah I was livid bro I thought
I can't believe he's doing this to me
he knows how I felt since we got here
yeah that was six hours
it was a four hour drive home yeah I I
remember I stayed in London that day and
I drove for the next day I had to I had
to did you still live in many then I
still live in Manny then yeah no you did
yeah yeah yeah I did I say that cheer
this that night you're lying did you
really yeah yeah that was a year ago it
was over a year ago no roughly a year
ago it was summer last was it really
yeah bro I'm still living money
times flying ah was it really yeah bro
time is gone wow time has really gone
yeah it was tail end of summer because
yeah I do remember I was speaking to the
estate agent whilst that was at thought
Park I was on the phone to them I
remember oh damn so we're having some
sort of issue with my move-in day or
whatever I remember
damn wow so it would have been August
September times August maybe so nearly a
year ago yeah geez Louise yeah man
that's nuts I had no idea crazy bro
crazy
um but yeah I've got a few more I'm just
reading them off what's a deal breaker
and a friendship involving me in your
drama I want to spectate not participate
yeah I've done that to you a few times
I've had to charge them
two or three occasions I've dragged you
in I've had to charge them all I'm sorry
every time but just put me in the corner
I'll do it yeah and the thing is I know
yeah I know and I just have to be
prepared at least at least I come clean
yeah as soon as I've done it I tell you
immediately what I've done yeah I have
to just accept it oh [__] you're a good
friend you're a good friend you're a
good friend having new best friends
every month facts yep facts yeah that's
a yeah yeah don't ever let me see
because obviously everyone wants to joke
about this Toby thing I love Toby more
than anyone in this room
so yeah those those jokes need to stop
I'm having a man stop me on road saying
where's Toby oh God that's crazy what's
happening leads oh who's on the way to
tattoo Oh So Random brother came up to
me in the middle of the street oh man I
was like yo what's going on I was like
what's up man it was like where's Toby
that clip was months ago
they're never gonna forget
um
they never could buy it I love Toby but
also yeah don't let me see just new
people in your story all the time yeah
yeah it's impossible say less I hear
that
uh if you don't know how to go oh if you
don't know how to go along with the LIE
facts
every every relationship friendship
group has done yeah bro if I
yeah I don't trust for a second I feel
like I'm from under the bus this guy
that is I would never trust
because I would never trust you to be
like
bro like if I say Okay question yeah
what the [__] is it yes yeah
laughs
bro okay random tell the truth I
actually don't believe everyone will do
this either it kind of would but I don't
think I don't think you get it okay this
guy would get immediately if I text you
randomly okay
4 P.M on a on a Wednesday and said
bro last night was sick
thanks for getting me home okay
I just text you that bro last night was
sick dancing get me home okay what are
you responding
but what the [__] are you talking
exactly
exactly exactly exactly question mark
yeah bro I can't believe you know yeah
yeah I was going to say that I can't
believe you didn't you didn't think I
would say that if you text me that on a
random one we didn't do [__] all last
night oh yeah
last night was lit see if you gave me
home I'm just messing I'm thinking what
are you talking about yeah I'm texting
back minor yeah yeah keep it short and
sweet I thought you got the wrong number
that's why I said
I said Ben yes the bronzer is yeah all
good bro yeah all good keep it pushing
keep it pushing me face to face talk to
me yeah yeah yeah
more Deets later on down the lines
oh that's funny
that's a question mark what are you
talking about
oh my God
that's hilarious
that's hilarious ah so funny oh all
right what's a deal breaker in the
friendship I was once told if you two
break up I'm going straight for her
wow
if you two break up I'm going straight
for her me and my girl we're happy
lovey-dovey you come and tell me yo big
man not gonna lie your babies fine she's
banging but yeah if you might ever break
up I'm going in on that straight in
there
that would take my breath away James I
wonder what to believe bro I don't know
what to believe
you know when you look at someone so
differently they physically look
different
oh my God I finally taking my glasses
wow
wow your face shape would change before
my eyes wow you are somebody else
you are somebody else
[Laughter]
[__] me
a few more broke as [__] ain't nobody
keep gonna keep paying for you facts
whoa facts you're gonna keep paying for
a friend all the time no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no not all the time
but also one thing a deal breaker one
thing I was actually having a discussion
with something about this the other day
one deal breaker for me in a friendship
one million percent
is like stinginess okay if my let's say
let's say my card let's say me and you
would just happen to be out and about in
London
and my car's just like someone's done
that floor to my car and it's canceled
so I've got no money on me maybe I've
got a little bit of cash but I can't use
Apple pay I can't do nothing yeah yeah
yeah if I tell you that yeah
and you don't immediately give me your
card and be like I'll use Apple pay use
my card and we'll sort the rest out
later we can't be boys
I tell you I'm [__] and we are
actively in Westfield right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah you need to tell me right
now yeah man I've got you yeah facts
otherwise nah yeah facts but then again
it depends on who you're with obviously
it's me and you it's different like
depends on who you're with oh yeah
specific time yeah if that scenario was
to take I don't I don't mean just like
an acquaintance or anything like that I
mean like we are friends yeah okay
Sailors
yeah yeah makes perfect sense makes
perfect sense
when he's always playing gay just come
out and be gay
first of all
I feel
specifically attacked
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro
wow that's hilarious I never put too
much said that that's hilarious just
come out and be gay come on stop playing
gay and just be gay James
I couldn't I I
really really would have to pick one of
two hats okay because it would be
wannabe who'd you actually think you're
talking to yeah yeah or two I'll be like
let's me then if you want me to begin
okay okay
yeah stop playing if you were serious
and we're like bro you know what yeah
stop playing game just be gay how about
that swear and I'll I'll leap in and be
like yeah I'd fall off my chair yeah
yeah fall back off yeah yeah that'd be
so petrified yeah I say run it again say
it again if that's what you want I'll
tell him to cut the cameras cut all the
cameras all of them that's so funny
wanting to borrow sex toys wow okay no
wow no no no no no no no no no no no
we're not doing that green bubbles in a
text
oh yeah it's jarring that that's
disgusting that is disgusting being a
backup friend wow also like you went
first draft first off for the meeting or
for the outing for anything that's not
that's not fair it's not fun if they
clap when the plane lands yeah that
happened when we when we landed in La
that happened did it yeah yeah people
few people around us and there was a
lady in front of us she rolled her eyes
she was American she rolled her [__]
yeah
it's so stupid when they make fun of you
a little too much
um it's a little too much yeah
when you're the go-to part of the joke
it's just not funny yeah it's just not
funny but am I your boy or not yeah and
no one else gets grilled for anything
it's just me yeah
last but not least if he's over six foot
and can't dunk it's just unacceptable
that's what the streets are saying yeah
deal breaker guys bro okay guys in the
comments let us know what your deal
breaker is all right say this that was
cool man interesting change of questions
yeah yeah yeah
um that was yeah interesting okay guys
welcome back welcome back
um thank you for joining us on this
lovely Monday it's beautiful Monday
sorry about the late arrival of last
week's episode
um I was happy about the abuse that I
was sent
um that day but also obviously deeply
hurt yeah
um one guy sent me a voice note bro
really bro one guy sent me a voicemail
on Instagram was like deep voice and was
like literally like what the [__] do you
I think you're doing
literally bro oh I'm gonna work all
[__] day I've come home waiting to
watch that in yeah you might need to
pull the [__] finger out
what's going on like a threat like a
threat oh safe it never reminds me of
you know um stormzy's album on that
first on the first track I think I'm
sure it's uh not big mike
um we're not brands in the intro and
storms he plays a voice note from her
brother and he's like oh he's storms you
blow it up big you release some music
yeah yeah
you [__] yes that rings a bell
honestly yes this guy was heated and I I
can imagine I know what them them nine
to fives I need to know I'm coming home
to something sexy yeah yeah yeah so to
have it yeah to have it not be there is
jarring but anyway guys I really
appreciate it I appreciate it that
everyone was so vexed that the episode
was late yeah that's a good sign that's
not on it you guys yeah you guys are
really really on it and the cult is in
full swing so we appreciate you guys and
um yeah man it's been a trip first leg
of our Log Cabin tour is done success
man it's been a crazy
yeah I've been super super so so thank
you to everyone who came uh it's been
amazing and obviously guys back to
regular programming if you enjoy the
show that much we ask that you prove it
okay so please head on over to
patreon.com shits and gigs and
come on man get in church get in get in
church and um let's go start supporting
the the babies supporting your daddy's
uh it's gonna cost you a measly three
pound a month don't be a day all you
need to do is run the piece of sng over
on patreon and you can watch every
episode
from the last three and a bit years you
guys tune in every Monday and you must
be thinking guys every time I tune in
it's either episode 281
283-285-287-289 where's where's the even
numbers it's not making sense is there
some kind of practical joke guys the
even numbers every even number is over
on patreon so head on over there binge
yourself silly jump in the Discord enjoy
all the perks and uh let us know how you
feel alright thanks guys if you are
watching on YouTube you already know
what to do help us get that gold plaque
help us get that juicy gold sexy little
plaque that we can put in the studio and
hit a million subscribers that's what we
want to do so we're we're hard tracking
on the way there
um we're what close to like 800k now I
think so we're flipping close now close
we're actually close close all you guys
that aren't aren't um subscribers you're
just listening and watching just hit the
button yeah yeah yeah please just smack
that that tasty little button and do
something for your boys and it'll make a
massive difference
um and guys yeah as always if you are
listening to the show on any audio
platform please leave a nice review
listen all the way through follow the
channel it means the world to us it
makes a massive difference for the show
um and your listening experience of
course because your boys will be happier
happy daddy means happy show that's
that's literally what it is facts so
anyway
guys
everyone's sharp for a minute and hear
me out
today's the day
so there's the day I'm gonna try and win
top five for the first time in like six
weeks I'm so nervous bro
I'm so nervous
that's so so nervous I'm tired of taking
else everybody get your boards out for
top five top five top five five top five
top five right guys everyone got their
balls ready yeah yeah so the top five
top five top five of this week is
top five brands
so I want you to tell me what the top
five brands are or have been up until
2023 like the most when I say top five
in incense or most successful most
profitable Brands just in general it
could be Tech it could be clothing
everything everything
up until 2023. oh God
okay so they have to still be in
business in 2023 or
they've they could have made x amount of
money between 1970 and 2022 and they
still yeah they're still in the top
there will still be part of the top five
slash top 10. all right even if they're
not still in business now
God damn it top five Brands bro yeah
there's too many there's too many
there's literally nothing
more of a widespread than this
[__] this up
at least you're chasing now because I
was annoyed about the uh the The Beatles
one and the music actually I think you
still would have won anyway if I got
Beatles yeah
yeah but I only went you didn't get
Queen and yeah I only went beyond sorry
I only went Elvis though because you and
Beyonce
what
how does that work huh
so he said his funds first and he said
Beyonce yeah yeah and then I had Beyonce
written down and I said I had Elvis also
and I thought well he said Beyonce
someone's going to say Elvis he was one
of my so when you said you were locked
in wait you switched that's exactly what
we're talking about what I'm saying
about the locking in so lock it in and
you have to pick me once I wasn't locked
in I was still I still had my I had mine
and I was thinking no no no every week
before anyone speaks it always says
locked in locked in locked in that means
whatever's written down now that you've
selected you have to say those ones
right
so what you're saying is once he said
his answer you change your locked in
answer to something else I had yeah
because you had Beyonce I had I had
Beyonce but I was I was in two minds
between those two
but he said it
that's a loophole yeah that's what that
is
awesome I'm not doing I'm not doing um
honorable mentions anymore okay all
right yeah yeah yeah that's a
controversial
REM you go first since you're locked in
first actually no let me tell you ten to
six and then yeah yeah tell me you're
five if we're doing that then
we have to turn on face now yeah if I'm
telling you ten to six if you turn into
ten to six yeah when we do it we have to
turn our face because if you're not
seeing boards yeah you could if if three
of mine I could just think of three more
on the spot and say that they're on my
board
number ten Tick Tock oh god I didn't
even think about social media
[Laughter]
number nine
Tesla wow really I almost put Tesla down
Tess is already a top 10 brand yeah of
all time I've put it I'll put Tesla did
you that's one of mine down
number eight Verizon no number seven
ICBC these are all American things isn't
it I think that's the International Bank
of China okay I see God okay six
the Samsung group oh God right and then
now we're doing it to one now Remy you
give me your five and turn them over
okay so I got
Amazon I didn't Tesla
Google
Apple
and Microsoft I know you might have
smashed me Google's under there's it's
underneath something there's a name for
you I can't remember the name yes
underneath uh I can't remember but still
it might yeah yeah Amazon tests like
Google Microsoft Apple Apple you you
might have smoked me my head was not in
the right space Tech Ellis I've gone
don't laugh I'm all right
Apple Microsoft Google PlayStation like
Apple
Microsoft see Nike like Microsoft was
for me James I've gone Apple Volkswagen
Disney McDonald's and like McDonald's I
didn't even think of McDonald's I know
Facebook's number one I know Facebook's
number one bro I'm living about it oh
come on Facebook's actually number 14.
it's really yeah wow for that all right
thank God cool it doesn't make me feel
any better about what I've got but gone
number five Walmart okay fine whatever
yeah I'll let that slide yeah go on your
heart's beating racing bro I can't stop
switching number four
please
[Music]
also please go on number three Google
yep I'm I'm just kidding to me let's try
it it's coming now give it to me I can't
win now because there's no way
I've only got this apple and Amazon
they've got to be up there I'm it's done
two
Amazon fam give me the dub give it to me
Apple number one
Apple Oh my days give me this dog four
out of five again well played around
let's go
um Volkswagen uh
they're not even in the top 25 Disney
are 23rd that doesn't make sense bro
would you mean Disney at 23rd
that's what he says bro they might make
money uh that was Tesla more than Disney
yeah that doesn't make any sense what's
what what list is this
because the party is controversial list
this is the global 500 2023 ranking yeah
okay so this is
ranking so when I asked
okay this is this is not what I asked
you at the beginning a hundred percent
what did you ask me so this is who's
making the most money in 2023
well there's a 2023 ranking yeah so this
is what ranks are the top 500 companies
or the top 500 brands in in right 2023
right now I asked you if a company
started in 1970 and went bust in in 2022
would they still hit these rankings no
this is a 2023 ranking top companies
that's why Tesla's in there
okay I'm with you I'm with you there's
no way I promise you there's no way
Tesla's made more money than Volkswagen
that's impossible in in this in the
space of dawn of time yeah yeah in 2023
definitely I feel cheated and lied to
McDonald's is 39th yeah and that's same
McDonald's
um I feel cheated and lied to I
specifically asked a question at the
beginning of the game to get
clarification on my top five
that's why I'm up for Volkswagen
his face
right it's five four five four two five
let's go 540 Rams taking the lead boys
let's go let's go ski let's go we've got
a new leader guys we've got a new champ
this is [__] bro and we'll re-up
next week we've got a new Champion next
week so explain the rules bro say less
say less [__] I'm sorry I know I'm
taking this too personally but that's
really Jarred me
oh
fun fact did you know Volkswagen is
responsible for five percent of all the
world's population um pollution
pollution um I think I did know that I
think I did know that that's why they
hit my top five bro
how'd you think I did know that for
God's sake that was top five guys that
was top five if you guys got any at home
right I just want to say something real
quick hit me
hmm
every Thursday
because I get nervous yeah talking about
it yeah real quick I already know what
we're talking about yeah
I don't feel like my stuff's peeling
back but it might be okay so I was
saying like I I inspect my hairline on a
daily yeah on a daily bread I'm in the
mirror just brushing forward I brush it
forward me fast I brush forward I brush
forward yes Mama waves look wave and I
don't brush because you obviously
brushes are this where I brush I turn it
yeah yeah so you get the extra length
extra I'm concerned yeah I'm concerned
um so
obviously I stress about my hairline so
consensus we spoke about this before
consensus is if your hairline's endless
reckons if his hairline starts to
dissipate he's lopping it off straight
off yeah yeah straight away no
to be fair you could you could you could
actually firm a ballet but I've got a
bit I have a bit as well if I'm asking
no no it's just your head shape your
beard and everything and I've seen your
dad
and yeah your dad doesn't look too
dissimilar from you I don't I can't
remember last time I saw my dad was hair
facts yeah yeah same with my Dad yeah
but I don't look anything like my dad so
I couldn't pull it off I need a light
skins need hair as well it's part of the
package yeah it's part of the package
bro you you date a light skin guy you
get hair you get a fade yeah that's what
you're bringing to the table that's what
we all do the same thing relaxing girl
curly hair like bad the package yeah
also beards connected connected
no do you want to grow a bed yes
I'd love to but I just get a bit of bum
fluff on my chin yeah
when I was holding you now do you're 22
22. I think I started growing man maybe
like 21 22. so this time bro I get
nothing yeah nothing I get a little
goatee
just keep it bro
I got two genetic patches
yeah every time I look at you I think I
think it's coming yeah yeah he's coming
right cool so General consensus is apart
from LS we're restoring yeah and
including this we want full luxurious
bids yeah we want to be men yeah facts
we want to be men bro okay cool so on a
restorative nature yeah let's chat about
this company real quick this comedy real
real quick is important
um it's called plant made so plant made
what they do
is there are completely
says in the name plant made company
black female-owned company props props
giving back to the black community
supported yeah who specialize in hair
and beard Health okay and regrowth
emphasis on the real growth I'd love to
hear it I can also be used on all hair
types which is Gang fun listen to me as
well yeah this is what's important to me
because this whole like
um
the whole like it's genderless and it's
for all Races and all hair types
I can't tell you how stressed I get
about products that I think aren't for
my hair because the way these men chat
to me is if I use L'Oreal beard oil yeah
my Beard's gonna fall off
that's what I speak to me and then like
the whole yeah yeah like has to be for a
certain building like not certain it has
to be for a certain hair type yeah you
can't use these products on your hair
these products got too many chemicals
this is I get stressed bro yeah I get
stressed and I get livid I want to know
what to put in my hair to make it silky
and fresh and shiny and
um I'm I don't want to be scared that
I'm making the thing worse because Tick
Tock could tell you oh I saw these
products you're putting in here sort of
chemicals that's the reason you're
losing your hair yeah and I'm like raw
all right maybe I should stop maybe
maybe I should stop and the next man is
saying no you need to put this in your
head to make sure it grows and I'm like
wow I don't know what to do which one do
I need bro I need a strong hairline just
tell me how to do it and I'll do it and
turkey's been bailing me yeah turkey's
been Belling me three prongs bam we see
you those Corners are edge up so yeah
yeah is is doing the thing so everything
no like no dodgy chemicals no fears
about whether it's the wrong hair type
that's the wrong part of your hair type
this is a girl's product this is a boys
product this is all one thing and Alice
especially you man
Derma roller yeah Derma roller on get in
there yeah yeah yeah open up their
follicles yeah the patches will be yeah
they'll be patched up it'll be full the
patches will be full and be patched up
um so yeah guys again all ages races or
hair types it's vegan it's natural it's
high quality 100 recyclable as well 100
recyclable bro and the names alone yeah
fam this thing's called a souffle a soil
souffle a soil soup flavor it's called
inches yeah yeah yeah yeah strength and
that growth come one yeah and [__] and I
like drizzle for that hydration that's
naughty they got naughty names they have
got noise so yeah it's a naughty product
with naughty names guys so yeah if
you're interested
um
notes will be in the description but
it's we are plantmade.com facts jump in
grab some and like obviously you know
why our beards are healthy you know why
headlines are healthy you know why we're
doing a damn thing because we have
products like this first so anyway there
we go that was a nice little segment
okay guys let's take a very quick break
you I already know especially if you're
living in the US you already know what
time it is it's playoff time guys it's
playoff time the playoffs are here and
your friends at marskip are here too and
they're making sure your balls are as
kissable as the Stanley Cup my guy
whether you're an NBA or NHL guy you
want to give your nuggets the best
clippers to rid them of pubes come on
wordplay the word please
the puns are pun in come on man all
right help them see the Summer sun don't
let your little Devils go wild you need
to use the lawnmower 4.0 and get your
boys as smooth as jazz
you can have the balls you can have the
balls of Kings by going to massgate.com
and using the code sng Sierra November
goal for 20 off add free shipping thank
you guys let's get back to the episode
um right anyway I've got a show
recommendation
I've actually got a show recommendation
for you man it's on Netflix okay you've
probably seen the the thumbnail or
whatever
it's called sanctuary
I don't think I have no I don't think
Halloween okay right show right or not
movie it's a show Eight Episodes in this
first season I haven't gone through a
first season I used to binge stuff
obviously you know yeah I haven't been
stuff like this in a minute I got
through this in like two days okay
they're an hour each of the episodes
well most of them about an hour
um it's called Sanctuary so the premise
is
oh god I've just seen that I've seen
what it the premise yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah fam so it is like um so it's a
Japanese show um
a Japanese show
with obviously like
how do I say live action there's a
live-action Japanese show it's about
um sumo wrestling so it follows
um uh a guy called Jose
who is looking to basically save up
money
to
um help reopen his dad's
uh Sushi business that went bust okay
in order to do that he's got a goal of 8
million yen that he needs to get as fast
as possible and he's a hoodlum bro he's
just like a criminal kind of guy he's
massive the super brother he's pops the
Suma bread okay Jose massive he's like
17 and all he does is just mug people
and take their money just smacks people
about okay it's a bully bro okay
basically he gets approached by some guy
um who runs uh what they call a stable
which is like where sumo wrestlers train
and live and all this stuff
um and he approaches ozone is like I
want you to be a sumo wrestler under my
like bad eyes yeah under my under my
banner
um and once you get to this certain rank
Sumo like you're gonna be making money
and he's like how much money is that bro
like get to this rank you'll be making
like a million a month
um
but Sumo what he learns when he gets
there is that Sumo has like a
long-standing
just like he's very very traditional
very respectful very traditional and he
doesn't respect [__] he's saying his
name's Jose yeah you've been saying sumo
sumo wrestling oh but you said Sumo said
did I yeah oh you just said it twice
that was like I thought I said Sumo has
um and yeah very traditional
et cetera Etc you have to be super
respectful you have to follow the rules
has like things you have to do basically
and he doesn't do any of it okay the
guy's a hoodlum he doesn't give a [__]
about anything or anyone okay I just
wants money money
um
and he's quickly learns that like he
used to be like really really good at
Judo and as obviously he loves like
street fighting and stuff like that none
of that is applicable in Sumo so he's
getting smacked up that [__] with the
eagle yeah yeah yeah his ego gets marked
I bet he can't believe it bro leave it
yeah Jose's ego gets destroyed in this
show okay so it's basically just a whole
season of from point A to point B
fam yeah the the last two episodes yeah
juicy yeah juicy okay he turns into a
MAG okay
oh oh it gives crazy anime already you
know already crazy anime and it's the
first actual like live-action Japanese
show that I've seen obviously watch bear
anime this is like the real thing it's
basically the same [__] it's mad and
then like Japanese culture fascinates me
if anyone who like is Japanese or
parents are Japanese or knows anyone I
need to understand this thing right so
in this show and I've seen it in like
other Japanese films and all this stuff
right yeah
any time these man go to a restaurant or
a bar or whatever yeah it's always one
rich brother with like a nine hoes oh
okay yeah yeah and they're always doing
really pervy creepy [__] and like
there'll be a a moment where he's like
trying to feed us some like some GEOS or
something yeah and she's like and he's
like no no no no no no they're too cute
you're too cute and she's like oh you're
playing with me you know what I mean
they do it all the time all the time bro
it happens in this show like 11 times
okay and I'm like
okay so this is a staple what's the
fascination about this what is this
thing what is this thing what is just
like an older rich guy with bare things
and he's just like are they I don't get
it are they prostitutes like are they
just like gold diggers like do they
actually fancy him like why is it always
one dude and he's doing that flirty flat
he's just squeezing titties man and they
are just squeezing teeth and Anime as
well bro and again I always like giggly
giggly stop stop mister and he's like oh
oh you're just so cute bro it's mad
his jokes because obviously you're
saying in English and I know they're not
speaking Japanese it makes much more
sense but like bro it's wild okay so I
need I need someone to tell me like I
need someone to tell me like what is
that is it yes and as well like the
whole the whole how they portray uh
there's in every anime there's always a
woman a busty woman or they're showing
underwear for no reason fam for no
reason Jose's Ting and this yeah Tigs
yeah
yeah yeah
always cleavage it's always bad yeah and
he can't believe it yeah
oh
it's crazy it's mad bro it's mad it's
matters man I don't understand the chord
I just really really want to wrap my
head around it okay but um the show is
fantastic okay gang I will definitely
definitely watch that I got someone
someone recommended me a show called
siren it's not out yet I checked it I
thought it was out it's out at the end
of this
um month it's somewhat giving
um physical 100 so fire and survive the
island the premises 24 female police
officers firefighters bodyguards
soldiers athletes and stunt women team
up by a team up by profession to
complete for a survival on a remote
island and they're just here just doing
Mad stuff oh damn yeah so and obviously
it's
um it's Japanese it's either Japanese or
called Korean it's Japanese or Korean
and you know they might go hard they
stay going hard so I'm definitely going
to watch that as well so shout out
um sanctuary and siren yeah I enjoyed
Sanctuary a lot and they left me on a
Cliff Hanger
I'll I'll put it up
right you've got a thread for us no um I
do the thread is ladies what goes
through your mind during this moment and
the picture is a lady's laying on a bed
and she's lifting up her pelvis and her
panties again drawn off
what goes through your mind during this
moment okay Celeste
I hope he finds it oh damn
I don't wanna
I hate hearing about reality questions
in when I'm locked in but there are you
all right
I think about my double chin and my
ingrown hairs on my Coots
[Laughter]
I don't know but I'm pregnant now oh
oh dear I'm pregnant now
I hope he knows what he's about to do I
pray I don't regret this hurry up and
put it in
see this is far too much like realistic
I want to hit source
my chick put I'm fat as [__]
fine I'm fat as [__] that was one time
yeah oh my God I don't even this is I'm
sorry I don't even remember who the girl
was but I remember
she was wearing a skirt yeah and tights
and heels and I was like yum like she
was a bit sturdy as well
um and was it the same study thing
because it's definitely in uni
it might be the same studs uh I'm trying
to deep it it might have been okay fam
oh this is Butters but it is what it is
yeah she lifted up her thing yeah Scott
drapes up the sky and she she lifted up
her pelvis yeah
and the tights were up to here God damn
ones okay and I could just see like
stomach under there like squeeze up yeah
she was doing up Spanx or whatever it's
called yeah yeah and I was like oh okay
I'm gonna have to take this off and then
like as soon as I like peeled yeah like
the first thing there was a deep red
mark like where in her skin and I was
like I'm over this whole situation
I'm over this whole situation and all I
us another thing I smelled warmth in
there oh must have been a hot day yeah
yeah it was a hot day and it damn I went
from 100 to zero immediately yeah so you
did it from the I I can't I probably did
yeah because I'm too much of a gentleman
not to
but yeah no
um it wasn't paying damn every other
time I've been in that situation it's
the length yeah yeah it's nothing better
in it yeah especially when you know when
like you're you're getting there yeah
and she hasn't moved a muscle yet yeah
and you're waiting for the go ahead yeah
yeah
thanks
all right ladies what goes through your
mind during this moment let's see if
this guy's really gonna do all the nasty
[__] he said to me in our messages
yeah
I need to be reminded I actually this is
a little point that might help some
people out
you have to remind him remind him of
what he said because once he slips that
in yeah
yeah he's not gonna remember any of that
yeah yeah I don't be thinking I'd just
be moaning as you're taking it off just
moaning oh no contact yet
say less
is my stomach in the way
oh for God's sake
oh I'd be trembling wet just waiting for
the first touch
straight off the skin I wonder if I look
like a rotisserie chicken from this
angle oh
God these are so Butters
he's actually just killing all the mood
bro this is straight As sand I told you
you told me he's sending me up and down
that was it I'm getting blood from head
to toe like it's just jarring bro that
was it bro
rotisserie chicken yeah
somewhere some are thinking over the top
and some are just down yeah facts wet to
the top there was
wet to the touch nah there was a threat
I was gonna do in the other episode but
I'm actually going to do it right
because it correlates yeah yeah it ties
in say less this is for the guys okay
this is for the guys okay guys
why did you smash and never go back okay
okay bro some of these man first of all
so this was a Instagram post and
um it was all comments the rest of it
was all comments from the guys
women
I love you lot I really do
there was more women comments in there
cussing guys comments before not even
causing the guy's comments jumping in
there saying
ain't nobody talking to you
it's like yo man this is not your time
let's have fun let's let's complain
about stuff sometimes hey yo but these
were funny all right right why did you
smash and never go back yeah bro I
wonder I said the back shot air was
disturbing oh the back shot air was
disturbing oh my oh that's cool you know
that yeah yeah that vacuum that
vacuuming yeah and it's just running up
your torso into your nostrils yeah
okay yeah wow inside of me this is a
nine hour day yeah this is a nine hour
this is nine hour two of them clapping
yeah one guy just said basic post-nut
clarity
said her kids came in asking for Hot
Cheetos mid clap wow hot cheetah mom I
want some hot Cheetos Med clap made clap
yeah no no you'll never see me again
you'll never ever ever ever kids with
care man obviously if the doors closed
you know the doors closed for reasons
Implement rules in your house relax man
do you sign about it don't let just let
man run just run in here rampant I need
an iron fist yeah for the afternoon nuts
I need an iron fist in this house
what the [__]
get control of the yard
what is all of that
[Laughter]
oh yeah
yo fam sometimes you lock into character
so well
it's all of the Yard Man
Muslim parental advice mid clap that's
so jokes bro one guy said her son kept
calling me dad
oh no what do you mean oh God no that
will make my heart be in the wrong way
Dad I'd be so scared oh a question
open-ended oh is
that I'll grab his face and move him out
of the way fam oh no grab his face
I'm grabbing a juicer Capri Sun get on
my face bro oh no not today not never
young man dad oh that's scary hours bro
that's scary hours wow dead all day
that'll make me squeeze my drink quickly
let me squeeze my drink wow wow wow
our customer on the way out as well oh
one guy said it was too good
wow why did you smash and never go back
it was too good damn he's coming back oh
he has to go he's going but he's just
not been back for a while yeah
yeah yeah his two-story replies away
from running up in that yard he's going
back
wow her baby daddy came to me as a man
wow that's not a thing either that is
never a thing a baby daddy came to me as
a man wow okay I know you're up in there
but this is my family
I love her please stop please please bro
please that please that no no no you
can't mess with me like that because
I'll stop immediately yeah yeah bro I
know you are you're in it for a good
time but please bro please bro that's
that's the month of my kids please
please bro stop yeah yeah stop
stretching around like that
all right bro Silas
her pinky toe didn't have a nail on it
bro
so what was this just skin hard skin bro
oh
that would scare me just four painted
beautiful nails and then just some
crooked thing wow yeah yeah no no no no
no no no that's accidental work yeah
stop oh man
I found a half eaten sandwich when I
dropped my phone under the bed
under the bed half eel sandwich under
the bed she has no control you're a
[__] yeah she has no connection you're
a [__] wow what the [__] yeah bro that
[Applause]
what is that
because nothing like that should be
under a bed I would never know it was a
half in Sandwich because as soon as I
feel it I will jump out my skin and run
out
photo no phone or no phone keep it bro
wherever monsters under there can keep
it yeah that's disgusting that is
[__] disgusting bro coffee and
sandwich bro
oh bro that missionary stare was given
child support
oh she was looking inside his soul scary
not in there yeah that's not in there
not in there yeah
not in focused yeah that's scary
baby babies
her foot bottom cut my knee
her football caught my knee I'm trying
to figure out how and they were just
doing up
I don't even know trying to think
positions were they cuddling how small
is she how tall is he God knows wow God
knows but you're asking the wrong
questions
where's your foot get me wrong I
understand why is the football so hard
but how did it also happen I don't know
bro yeah yeah you need that you need
that pedicure ah fam last one
the coochie hair I can't even read it
but I have to say it off memory the
coochie hell yeah must have been so so
stop read the thing like a man what is
this bro man's covering his eyes and
peeking at the same time what the [__]
man read out
read out like it's meant to be read oh
farmer said the coochie hair felt like
the green side of a sponge no
that's so specific as well so rough and
so specific wow the green the green side
of a sponge that's the scour inside that
is that's where you get the dry food off
that's how you get rid of dry food bro
the green side wow no that's a horrible
yeah that's the roughest oh that's the
roughest of hair wow that is a shame
she's
that's horrible that's a whiff and a
half I've got to say something hit me
let me switch more
I saw something the other day that shook
me to my core it's a bit dark and I
don't want to make light of it okay but
guys sometimes when I'm nervous I laugh
I have to get on my chest okay
so
I may have said this before
this won't apply to
people outside of the UK but the M1 is
the worst Road in this country okay the
M1 is full of traffic all the time okay
so I'm on the M1 last week
I'm only M1 last week due south
just minding my business I think I was
going to Milton Keynes I'm on there and
I get stuck in traffic bro bumper to
bumper traffic and I'm like ah this is
jarring so I'm there for literally like
20 minutes half an hour just two miles
an hour at a time
as I get closer
it's one of them ones that I complain
about all the time where the only reason
is traffic on my side is happening on
the other side and everyone's slowing
down yeah yeah and I'm here thinking you
bastards bro yeah I've got places to be
speed up yeah stop I don't care what's
happening over there speed up yeah
brother
when I got when I got there yeah I
slowed all the way down I swear I
stopped the car I'll swear there was a
brother sat on the edge of a bridge
about to jump
oh my god brother there was a bra sat on
there so you know when it's like when I
say something on the edge I don't mean
sat on the railings yeah I mean sat on
the other side of the railings on the
small steep of concrete yeah that holds
the bridge up so the the bridge that
you're you go under when you're on the
M1 when you're under one of those yeah
one of those overhead Bridges oh she was
gonna jump onto the M yeah jump straight
on the street
to get hit by a car he would have died
before he had got a car but yeah yeah
yeah yeah he was gonna jump straight off
there as a police officer trying to talk
him down
wow and I was like
raw my my guts felt funny pause my guts
felt all jiggly and funny and I was like
somebody about to kill himself and do
not mind them do you know how I know he
was real he had no shoes on I'm gonna
say that I knew you were gonna see how
no shoes on he had no shoes on bro I
said right serious yeah yeah he wanted
to feel it [__] he wanted to feel it
yeah he hasn't even planned for the
journey home yeah he's ending it today
bro he has no intention of going home
wow he had no shoes how did you know I
don't know it just came to mind but I
said he said let's see on the fingers
I've got no shoes on I just had that
feeling I just had that feeling bro
but I had no shoes on damn and he had
his fingers he was leaning over as well
he was sat on it sat on the edge yeah he
locked his fingers back here he was
screaming a policeman all I could see
was barefoot and I was like oh my God
Jesus
so yeah anyway I carried on my day I had
to go on the M1 on the way back and I
thought I don't know what I'm going to
see yeah all I know was traffic was
moving again okay I don't know which way
we left but something happened Saturn
happened and traffic was moving again
wow that happened to me I can't remember
what Emma was on but I was I think I
could have been I was definitely still
living the money I could have been
coming from money to London or vice
versa
um but again same again traffic on my
side but it was an event happening on
the other side but when I said there was
traffic there was traffic bro I might
have said on a product I can't really
remember
um as I was getting closer and closer
and closer and I realized all my days
are not even my side there's there's
Chaos on the other side because for like
a good 5-10 minutes as we were creeping
creeping I was noticed there's no cars
coming on the other way
yeah yeah yeah what's going on so the
closer and closer I got I started seeing
like individual police cars individual
police cars and then I saw there was a
helicopter there was there was a a like
a not a go-kart um car but like
um like a quad bike a quad bike car desk
thing and flipped over oh dear a car and
another car murked and they had
um they had barricaded this the viewing
point of the cars on my side with like
sheets of paper oh I've never seen that
before just sheets oh that's death just
sheets yeah someone's dead in there yeah
yeah like no they didn't want anyone to
see what was happening it was oh
I've never seen that in my life what I
saw was the flip quad and a helicopter
ambulance ambulance ambulance and a
white sheep okay so all the way across
okay yeah yeah that would give me that
mess it was mad they'll give me numbers
for a few days but yeah that Barefoot
thing spun me Fam wow spammy I haven't
stopped thinking about since wow yeah
that's um that's scary bro to be it to
not even to be able to witness that but
to by going about your business and to
witness that is um there's some scary
stuff man for real fro anyway uh yeah
let's lighten this [__] up am I the
[__] am I the [__] for that
getting my wife and am I the answer for
not getting my wife anything on Mother's
Day
I 34 mil did not buy or get anything
from my wife on Mother's Day and let me
explain why
my wife and her friend planned planned a
trip to the beach for four days which
fell on Mother's Day so I thought to
myself that since I'm watching the kids
while she's gone that would count as a
gift since she wouldn't be here to
celebrate that day and I would um get
home that night and would get home that
night on Mother's Day
she gets home and realizes that I didn't
do anything for her and Leia tells me
that she's upset and the message was and
the message was received loud and clear
I tried to explain my reasoning and
thought and the thought process but she
didn't agree so am I the [__]
um short one yeah super short so so
Mother's Day Mother's Day she went away
with a girl for four days um to the
beach the day she came back or the day
she came back and landed on Mother's day
but she came back that night the pops
was at home or the husband was at home
with the kids so he didn't really feel
the need to do anything to celebrate
Mother's Day considering she wasn't
there
um when she came back that night she was
like oh well Bob is there a while ago
she expected something she got nothing
back and forth
it's easy also interesting uh I think a
kind of easy one yeah okay yeah just get
it like I can understand like not making
a big deal but just get something in it
this is a I don't know if it's
necessarily [__] territory it's just
like Common Sense facts it's not
obviously yeah it's just we're just
you're not you're just not doing up
Common Sense bro yeah if it's Mother's
Day and she's gonna be there on that day
we're gonna visit the morning or even or
whatever get her sighting bro just save
yourself the grief yeah bro what is this
foolishness a man said also one [__]
think of what he did say was I thought
it was gift enough that she'd been away
before this and I was looking after the
kids yeah look after your own use is not
a present to someone else yeah facts
what are we talking about yeah yeah
um and the fact that he probably
he I think he is an [__] because he
in his mind thought like you said ah I'm
looking after the kids and two
by the time she comes back the day will
be done she's gonna be naked whatever so
there's no real reason to celebrate
because but he's been thinking about
that all day yes but he knows for a fact
what he's doing is wrong yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's all things in
his mind his reason is correct yeah he's
calculating reasons why not to get her a
gift and if you can justify reasons not
to get a gift you might as well just go
shopping again so that's why he's the
[__] thanks gang we we did that yeah
yeah we really did that [__] we're good
at this anyway guys uh thank you for
today very Buffy episode as always
um and guys you know what to do head on
over to patreon.com
and cash us on Thursday thank you very
much
[Music]
foreign